and prenatal care is essential to
deliver a healthy baby
and staff and students over at toro
university are now working to expand
medical care
so everyone has access bianca holman
live there this morning to explain good
morning to you bianca
hey good morning alex so yeah this is an
incredible partnership and program
between
tour university and united health
foundation and
again this health care for our women
experiencing homelessness
is so important and i'm actually joined
by a practicing ob gyn here in the
valley dr alan thank you for joining us
this morning
we need more ob gyns right well thanks
for having me
we need to know that we are ranked 47th
in the nation when it comes down to
women healthcare wow
women healthcare providers and we have
growing population and we
need to make sure that every patient
every woman gets high quality care
and this partnership is going to be very
important to get service to underserved
women throughout the community yeah so
again educating the next generation of
ob gyns to help bring in more babies to
our valley
and ensure that our mothers are healthy
and also there's a technology portion so
these students are holding uh tell us
what they are this is a sonogram right
yes this is the future of our country
our city right now and state
these young students what they're
holding here is a handheld ultrasound
when they go into the field in their
mobile unit
they're going to be able to assess
pregnant women where they are
in our practice we've done a great job
in southwest medical of putting
clinics on bus lines so patients get to
us you'd be surprised some patients take
four transfers
with this technology and with these
young students and their physicians in
the mobile unit
it's gonna really change the way
underserved communities are getting care
so this will ensure again we're bringing
in healthy babies we have healthy moms
right so how does it make you feel to
know that we're going to be servicing
our community in this way
it makes you feel very good because
every woman deserves a chance to have
great prenatal care
great prenatal care leads to healthy
babies decrease our infant mortality
and levels set the feel for all of us
because the babies are our future
yeah they definitely are yes and so
again this is going to be on the mobile
units
being extended to our women experiencing
homelessness
and so anything else you want to share
just about this partnership and again
the work that tour university is doing
with the united health foundation i
think it's a great partnership
because when you train young physicians
to be able from their first year
on to their graduating year to become
able-bodied
obgyns or family practice taking care of
these patients we can all benefit as a
whole
city and a state yeah this is wonderful
so
again great information great program
happening here at torah university